before we start today's video we need to
ask you a question are you alone in the
room seriously are you alone you may
think the room around you is empty but
how can you really know that right think
of the technology out there being
developed by groups like darpa the cia
or even the scp foundation secret agents
in cloaking suits could be standing
around you right now watching your every
move without you even knowing you could
tell someone about this but if you did
they'd think you're crazy and nobody
believes crazy people do they sometimes
people's whole worlds just collapse one
day they're living happy successful
lives with families and friends who love
and care about them then the next day
they're truly convinced that the us
government is tapping not only their
phone calls and their emails but their
thoughts perhaps even putting dangerous
brain waves directly into their mind or
they start to believe that those loving
family members and friends seek to do
them harm maybe they start to believe
their food is poisoned and stop eating
causing them to waste away from
malnutrition most terrifying of all
maybe they start to see things that
nobody else could see monsters that defy
rationality and shake the very soul
terrible terrible things these are all
sadly relatively common symptoms of
someone suffering from a severe case of
schizophrenia a mental illness with a
wide range of detrimental effects to
sufferers first and foremost giving them
an incredibly complicated relationship
with reality there's sadly a lot of
misconceptions in the media about people
who suffer from illnesses like
schizophrenia painting them as unstable
individuals who present a danger to the
people around them in reality people
with a condition like these are three
times more likely to be a victim of a
violent crime and they're also more
likely to be a victim of something else
too
like we said earlier sometimes people's
worlds just collapse and in severe cases
they might simply drop off the map and
nine times out of ten the reason for
that is
scp-870 the maybe they're monsters take
the experience of katrina wayne she was
an office temp in tallahassee florida
with an undiagnosed case of mild
schizophrenia for the most part she was
able to operate just fine at her job
getting her work done at a satisfactory
level while also maintaining a decent
social life after hours it came as a
shock to everyone when she began
screeching horrifically in the middle of
the office she backed herself up against
the wall picking up nearby objects and
throwing them into the aisles at some
invisible foe and this isn't a metaphor
there really was an invisible foe moving
towards her and only she could truly see
it seeing the huge scaly body of a
mature alligator from the florida
everglades moving towards you would be
scary enough on its own but this wasn't
any ordinary alligator its long
reptilian head had three eyes instead of
two and it moved towards her on eight
huge articulated spider legs it was like
something straight out of a nightmare
katrina was put on leave due to a
stress-induced mental breakdown and
prescribed a course of antipsychotic
medication by a psychiatrist she
disappeared from her home without a
trace a mere two weeks later or take the
story of daryl simon he was a mechanic
working in michigan with a family
history of schizophrenia though he'd
never been officially diagnosed himself
he was working on the engine of a
vintage corvette when something strange
happened his garage began to fill up
with smoke he considered that at first
perhaps it was some kind of engine
malfunction causing smoke to belch out
of the old corvette's tailpipe but then
he saw something standing in the smoke a
human figure daryl suddenly felt a
profound sense of dread seeping into his
mind he grabbed a monkey wrench and
began to slowly approach the intruders
standing in the smoke it was only when
he was already too close that he
realized the figure wasn't just standing
in the smoke it was made of smoke the
second he noticed this the figure's eyes
opened glowing red it's smoky face
opened into a wide toothy mouth and let
out an ear splitting shriek daryl
suddenly found himself running as the
creature gave chase he threw his wrench
as it ran it breezed through the
creature's semi-intangible form daryl
was found later that day huddled in the
corner of his garage muttering
incoherently after seeing a mental
health professional and sharing his
story he was given a schizophrenia
diagnosis he was given a mix of talk
therapy and medication and seemed to be
improving over time he would
occasionally report hallucinations of
the man made of smoke watching from the
corner of his eye but it was dismissed
as nothing more than that a
hallucination a month later he was gone
never to be seen again but he wasn't the
only one to fall victim to the anomaly
shirley nicholson a retiree whose
schizophrenic symptoms developed later
in life was having a quiet evening in
her home when she first encountered an
instance of scp-870
she was watching a game show on
television when she heard a strange
noise coming from her kitchen a rustling
like someone was messing with the food
inside her fridge of course she always
had a tendency to hear things which was
why she wasn't that nervous when she got
up and walked to the kitchen that sense
of confidence didn't last long when she
entered the kitchen she saw the fridge
door open with the back half of what
looked like a giant ant emerging from it
her breath caught in her throat that
giant ant which seemed to be eating the
food inside her fridge suddenly froze
seeming to realize that shirley had
entered the room when it backed out of
the fridge shirley couldn't help but
scream instead of antennas and mandibles
the giant ant had a grinning human face
as shirley screamed the giant ants human
face began to cackle with sadistic glee
its jaw began to stretch open impossibly
wide exposing the never-ending darkness
within shirley turned and ran as the
creature skittered towards her at a
frightening speed adrenaline kicked in
and surely ran for her life as the
monster pursued her through the house it
was only when she ran out into the
street and was seen by others in this
bizarre outburst that the horrifying ant
monster seemed to disappear and several
weeks after her schizophrenia diagnosis
shirley nicholson sadly disappeared too
before she vanished she made a panicked
9-1-1 call where she screamed down the
line that the monster had come back no
explanation has yet to be found but
there are more cases to be investigated
still don jones who had a documented
history with schizophrenia had his
scp-870 experience while waiting for the
bus out of town late one october evening
he was checking his phone at the bus
stop when he saw a figure shuffling
towards him in the distance he tried to
ignore it at first years of therapy had
taught him to try his best to ignore
these strange little anomalies he had
been medicated for years and while
occasionally he had minor episodes he'd
lived with the condition for long enough
now that he'd learned how to cope that
was when the strange shuffling figure
got closer don looked up just for a
moment to see the thing coming towards
him out of the dark it was about the
size of a child though a little shorter
because of how far the creature was
hunched over literally hunched the
entity had a rather prominent hunchback
but this wasn't nearly as noticeable as
the thing's face it had the head of a
particularly mangy looking parrot its
curved beak caked in what looked like
old blood this was stranger than some of
the hallucinations he'd suffered in the
past it looked more tangible more real
even after years of medication and
therapy he felt nervous as the thing
approached him on some subconscious
level he knew the thing intended to harm
him in one way or another when it opened
its mouth and sunk the bladed tip of its
beak into don's hand he knew that he
wasn't dealing with any mundane fantasy
here he screamed and ran off into the
night the monster giving chase he later
reported the incident to the police but
his fears were written off when his
medical history came to light everyone
just assumed the man was experiencing
another episode and that the wound in
his hand was self-inflicted of course as
you've probably gathered by this point
poor don jones would disappear without a
trace not long after still the
testimonies get freakier a warehouse
security guard alex landry had his
terrifying encounter while on the job he
was on his nightly patrol when he heard
a strangely soft skittering noise coming
from inside the warehouse he deployed
his flashlight and ran inside after
radioing for assistance he was expecting
maybe an escaped animal or a young
hoodlum messing around inside what he
didn't expect was a face-to-face
encounter with pure terror as his
flashlight beam traced its way up to the
top of the warehouse he saw a monster
crawling across the ceiling it was a
giant 15-foot long centipede but instead
of having normal centipede legs it had
scores of twitching grasping human arms
he was found in a comatose state by his
partner and spent the brief rest of his
life in a psychiatric facility before
you guessed it disappearing without a
trace and most exhilaratingly we come to
the tale of mr holgate which both ends a
little more hopeful for him but paints a
grim picture of what happened to
everyone else mr holgate had encountered
a spider-like creature with a freakish
number of legs which he soon realized
only he could see during his periods of
observation he'd seen the creature both
devour a ruler as in the measurement
device not a king as well as swallow a
human hole after an extended period of
stalking the victim leaving nothing
behind just like the scp-870 instances
had done to all of their other victims
when the monster eventually came for
holgate he was ready it ran screeching
towards him on its too many legs and
holgate whipped out a gun and shot it
the foundation had prioritized the
capture or destruction of scp-870 it's
believed to be not a single instance but
an entire species living out there
preying on humans and hiding in the
space between our perceptions even two
schizophrenic people looking at the same
instance will report seeing completely
different entities the monsters are all
the more dangerous due to the fact that
sufferers of severe schizophrenia often
report hallucinations of strange
monsters or entities so their pleas for
help are often ignored by neurotypical
authorities neurotypical meaning those
who don't experience any form of mental
illness personality disorder or
developmental condition people who could
never see scp-870 coming until they're
already being swallowed whole the lead
researcher on the scp-870 case follows
up the file on the monsters with an
ominous note that leaves little comfort
for even those of us who don't suffer
from schizophrenia the note reads i
personally don't believe that the
schizophrenics are really seeing
870 furly they can just see it more than
us we don't see it because our brains
aren't made to see it the schizophrenics
their brains are wired up just that tiny
bit differently and they can see it just
a tiny bit more these things have the
perfect camouflage and we simply are
unable to see through it to return to
what we said at the very beginning of
this video look around the room and
answer our question are you
alone
now at least you know the answer to that
question may not be as simple as it
seems now go check out evil monster
created by scp foundation
scp-2419 the laughing men and revenge of
d-class ghosts
scp-4973 dead men walking for more scary
anomalous beings that'll have you
looking over your shoulder